alexandre benalla à nous et deux
contrats de sécurité avec des oligarques
russes
un premier en juin 2018 alors qu'il
était en poste à l'élysée contrat pour
le compte 10 candeur mahmoud of un
proche de vladimir poutine
mediapart révèle l'existence d'un
deuxième contrat signé avec un autre
proche du président russe signé cette
fois après son limogeage de la
présidence en décembre 2018
en tout le montant de ces contrats russe
s'élève à 2,2 millions d'euros
pourtant alexandre benalla avait affirmé
devant le sénat sous serment ne pas
connaître l'existence de ces oligarques
je voulais vous demander si vous
connaissiez monsieur iskander makhmoudov
je ne connais pas cette personne nous à
part à travers la presse je ne les ai
jamais rencontrés
de son côté la commission d' enquête
parlementaire reste prudente sur un
éventuel parjure elle rendra ses
conclusions en même temps que son
rapport attendu prochainement et je ne
veux en aucun cas préjuger de ce qui
sera une autre décision à nous
co-rapporteur nos propositions faites à
la commission des lois
pour fabrice arfi journaliste à
l'origine des révélations
alexandre benalla a bien menti à de
nombreuses reprises devant le sénat on
l'entend dans les enregistrements
révélés par mediapart et d'alexandre
benalla et de vincent kra ce que la
police puisse mettre la main sur le
contrat russe qu'il faut absolument
cacher alors on change le montage
financier ont créé une nouvelle société
qui est dirigé par qui ont sous main par
alexandre benalla et puis quelques
semaines plus tard un nouveau contrat
devant les sénateurs
monsieur benalla droit dans ses bottes a
dit qu'il n'avait rien à voir avec aucun
contrat russe c'est faux la commission
d' enquête du sénat pourrait signaler la
sphère au parquet en cas de parjure
avérée alexandre benalla risquerait cinq
ans d'emprisonnement et 75 mille euros
d'amande